this is a production of cornell
university
thanks to the professor again for
tonight's introduction um
so thanks everybody to attend this
seminar
um
so my talk would be today is
slightly different from normally like
you by origin orientated seminar but we
talking more like
the technology based
so i hope well we're using a good
example to damages the case how really
the new technology or application can
help
uh leverage
the plantar science particular brand
science and research
so
before i
started my talk i i you know because in
past two years the pandemic a lot of new
graduates in the new faculty may not
know
who are what we're doing so i try to get
very briefly
to to tell everybody what
what we are doing
um
so basically
we are we're located we're located first
floor or by technology building it's
it's just
and we have a five current five staff
member
and uh and uh you know we have mainly uh
we have one position open for
for um
tech position for metabolomic site but
um
mainly we are we are playing with the
keys we have the tool the tool called
mass spectrometer and that's the key
part of to a very expensive one but can
do a lot
um
and facilitate research um a lot of
things that we are going to talk about
today
and obviously by informatica tool here
and this is the help of us to be able to
do the data analysis
so so this is a basically service a lot
of people don't know i really encourage
everybody if you get a chance to look at
the website we listed
all
and this is the proteomic side the main
thing is today we will talk about the
major things but one of them
a lot of people were using called the
protein protein integration protein like
integration we normally use an ip
product and the cross-linking respect so
um i i just mentioned that under
untargeted metabolomic size other than
today we talked about we also will talk
about we're doing untargeted epidemics
and then we're doing a lot quite a bit
is a target
once you know your molecule um
what the component you're looking for
you're trying to do absolutely or
profiling then we're using target
approach
to do analysis
so
as i said today we're going to talk
about really the three different types
of on technology or worker for law and
just the very past two years developed
and one cover with four metabolic alpha
four polyemic has a two all related
metabolomics and then um i will show you
each of the case done done and here
what's the the the technology and detail
about
and obviously we have a three case
to damage demonstrate
one of the cases is it's called the new
technology name called the real-time
search
it means to the three person so a lot of
biology viewers probably don't know
what's the ms3 mean i think i will
explain a little bit late at this point
but the technology coming out in 2019
the summer of 2019
uh it's called this is a dramatically
improved the quantitative proteomic
which is most widely used the
application for proteomic site so um
so so one of the you know this is the
mainly the improve is the the outcome
would be increased significant accuracy
and the realist report which is really
helped improve the
premium coverage so we talked about it
by that time to the sum of 2019 we have
a project that is coming just
for um
from
the the hydrogen sulfide that treated
the underlying of a
figure so we're trying to and they just
we just acquired the data using the
traditional way and then this is the
perfect time we got the new equipment
the new technology and we want the test
and this is how our facility posted our
and she would be you know deliver that
the test results i and so i was able to
show
so
we just mentioned what's the technology
about it is for
for quantitative proteomics
but um
so really uh one of the quantitative
proteomics we use in the
is called the tmt tag isobaric attack
labeling approach
and the tandem the tmd target the full
name called endometric and the the the
biggest advantage of this technology is
they can do multiple plagues
currently about two two years ago they
can deliver you know i mean
they can deliver so-called 16 sample you
put it together you can quantify at the
same time actually two months ago almost
three months ago now they deliver 18. so
we have we can now doing 18 practice
together so to to just make a long story
trying a little bit detail what's that
technology about the beauty of the
technology is the reagent it's called
the isobaric reagent that reagent they
put the reporter on here using different
isotopes labeled and they're using the
balance
group to balance that the mass and
therefore what that's what they call the
isobaric mass they have a 16 or 18
different reagents but their mass
isobaric would be the same okay so when
you do you know i mean this is 10 years
ago i did that for also plant biology
this is department it's just the uh the
joy is just
more berry and by then we only did the
16 six plus and once you label the
reagent with the peptide peptide level
label and when you don't respect
analysis
in the service scan we call that when
just a major peptide they actually add
the same peptide from six example or
1618 sample they're all added together
actually boosts your signal but when you
do ms2 what caught the emits two
sequences when you start sequencing all
ms3 sequences then you get the fragment
the reporter iron you leave because the
balancing are gone and then releases
then you are able to do connotation so
that's why this technology allows you
simultaneously identification and
quantitation
now
now the problem
that the downside of traditional
technology this way is we call to do a
message to connotation with the negative
peptide and sequence it and then get the
connotation the problem is they call it
ratio compression the accuracy
significant compromise the why they
compromise because any iron when when we
select a peptide what we call the iron
in respect so you're always isolated in
some background behind so for
identification no problem because this
is the dominant you can
you know uh identify what the other
pepper type but the full quantitation
they add all background on the other eye
so that's why cause the ratio is another
accurate they call the ratio complexion
sometimes called distortion okay so this
is a was really published um
to 10 years ago so people coming out
you know a solution how we address that
because we know the
the ratio we're coming out is not as
accurate as we hope um what are we going
to do what they're going to do is
respect you know they can do multiple
station fragmentation that's a message
well here we call it a message to the
third so the way you do what you
isolated your peptide you want to
quantify after labeling and then you do
fragment and after the fragment instead
of the regulator measure the
quantitation then you go to the next
level so called the image to the third
you know selected the product and go to
the investors then you look at the
compensation obviously your background a
lot of low so but generally speaking by
doing that then you add a problem is the
low sensitivity because you selected one
so so people developer called single
chop recursive selection space you can
select up to 10 up to 20 now uh on
frequencies and normally people do 10
and then boost the sentence for the
quantitation so that's you're getting
away with it so the ratio obviously now
you are a lot better you can see it down
here and you know ms2 original was 10
now become four but when you do the the
the it messes to the third you're almost
getting the real no interference uh on
on ratio
so
um so but any new technology you
developed you of you you're getting
benefit on one side you created another
one and that's one of those typical
example we want to show
but you see
this is the otherwise we call the
investor that is great the message
accuracy is now solved but the problem
is created another problem is because
you need addition the scan time to do a
message so third so
what happened then was you yeah your
accuracy improved but your number
what we call the pretty on coverage now
you drop to only 65 percent if you have
let's let's say 80 000 and this is
probably only 5 000 you can get so
people don't like that
of course but now you have the
compromise you either take a high
accuracy or you take the low coverage
now so that's one of the the technology
latest about two years ago
they
discovered that they called the
real-time search so the this is the the
real-time surgery the reason that what
they're basically saying we can speed up
the the message to the third originally
do by doing real-time searching what
that means when when we
look
retrospectively
the original data would find that a lot
of ms recent spend we spent the time on
that but is
is no quantitation information is we
call that it's a it's in productive
spectrum
therefore now
when you do real-time searching when
you're for the real time you know this
has to be the real peptide then you do a
message to the third so by doing that we
will really speed up and offset the
original we called the the time addition
time you need to take and this is coming
to that you know we can look at it and
come to see how much we close the gap so
original approach we use in the ether
orbital fusion we got but now the new
technology called
eclipse we are able to do that
so
now here's the results obviously we now
have we also um optimize those
parameters there's a lot of perimeter
one um parameter we're obviously using
isolation window so after we optimize
that isolation window i i'm not trying
to give too much detail so
after we all
normalize you can see this is the
original fusion we're using regular ms
sap mystery we can close gap to the 75
percent originally most people were 65
or 70 a little bit but then now using
the latest the real-time search
everybody can see it obviously this new
machine is a lot better than all the
generation is it's getting the more but
it's closed almost ninety two percent
the global origin from 65 now to 92
percent that's why
we get the deeper income but also data
quality you can see the data quality a
lot better in terms of ratio compression
the accuracy uh the hidden method you
can show a lot of this is a this is the
the data a lot reflected actually the
abundance change in the in the real
biological sample
so
um because of that we didn't you know
we're using better as i said before the
project as a demonstration so which is
the aircraft using real-time search to
find and find out um by doing real-time
search for the quantitation we find the
additional so-called novel biological
pathway involved the the cell on
apoptosis
so and obviously the graduates need who
submit the same but they test a couple
of that pathway and they use continuous
assay obviously to to look at it and
compare the two different groups located
if there is a broken under the dna
fragment it has and then he also did the
password others that apoptosis the
pathway they also several mark gene he
did itpci and to them essentially it is
increased by the uh and hydrogen sulfide
treated group and then obviously he also
did the west broad
uh analysis to confirm some of the
protein change
so after we did that we did a lot of
planned because we this is the damage
the case of the technology it works well
in our facility we now exclude using
that um and then professor gang has a
project coming out we did the plan a lot
of random work has not been published
but uh president
is waiting to share their data so i'm
happy so now i just show hit you know
this is the work we have been done for
professor ken's lab
um this is a professional level is
focused on investigating the regular
mechanism of uh levers necessities and
you know i mean this is the sample we
did it with the parallel um product
proteomics and phosphorus for leaves and
ended up using rubber diocese as a as a
model system
so what what their level finally is
um they find that the uh knockout a gene
called the senescence associated genius
iv which is really a novel protein
kinase what they find was really
excellently the
the level on synthesis
and that's interesting that's why the
project created by here is where we're
trying to identify um
what's the target protein on target by
sag all phosphorylated by sag and
related the liver sinuses okay
so in the real time extreme design we
actually designed you know using three
different leave stages i believe this is
is the ag data of the germination 40
days 45 days and 49 days and then we
designed it with two um different uh um
weather type versus mutant actually tmt
uh 16 plugs but done here we just want
to quickly show the the wider type of
results and then then just a simple so
the way we just for simplify it is to
demonstrate how that works um so the the
one ceo gmd label that you put together
i mean obviously that replicates a 90
the more than 90 that we use in the
four-year regiment for phosphor uh
polyamic analysis and then only ten
percent that we're using grover that's
what we use in uh real-time search rts
so
here's the results and then this is
quite an impressive result so we got to
go over like almost more than
six thousand that's that's the routine
the more important things that we find
that you know um
professor against labor find the more
than 200 new
um
you know uh sinister associated gene or
correspondent operating obviously and
the from first of all predominately
will also find 450 new sites and that
seems that's all also very impressed uh
and then here when you look at the
principle component analysis of those
three
different stages is really separated
very well and then data show quite a
reproducible and obviously everybody
will do the motif analysis and you can
find and there's two top
you know you know map kinase and the
casing kindness too those are become the
top kinase motifs we find for the
peptide we identify and this is a this
is uh everybody know it makes akp is
respond
you know responsible for cell
cellular response in particular in
applied
array of the
stress okay so so that's pretty much um
ratio of this case so the take-home
message for this one is i hope to
convince you you are well at least wish
you a real time such a close gap from
original predictive 65 to 70 or
something like that we get more than 90
and then
the second point is very important that
this is not only we you know improve the
gap but really accuracy and that
accuracy is very critical to make a
possible even confident detective small
change because in biological originally
because visual complexion we have to
look at okay above certain levels but
now allowed us we routinely can as long
as your data
replicates the data and statistics show
significant change even now can down to
one point two one point three four the
change you still see the significant
difference so
that's the point i want to make for
for that new technology now i want to
switch the gear to the metabolomic side
so in our facility we
recently focus on um the last year we
focus on generated a so-called
spectral building in-house component
special library
so in this talk we are trying to
demonstrate how this is the library
really helped facilitate antarctic
metabolomic
metabolomics and we're using plant as an
example and this is a work that was done
in my uh the two um
the chicken in the facility they did the
enormous work and
to get away with it uh this is really
helpful so everybody probably will ask
why
we need
you know beauty library so for untapped
metabolic untargeted metabolomic we're
always again the same we're trying to
identify screen out what's the
difference between the two sales data or
health white or mutant wider type
okay so so the way originally
metabolometer we basically copied like a
proteomic we're using
public databases which is available with
doing search we find and then identify
what the component shows up but turns
out
it's actually a lot of false
positive identification or quarter
annotation and the reason why is because
public database no rotation time that's
very important point
so because on those days our mistake is
very accurate we can down to one ppm or
just the less than two
two million dollars in difference so we
can accurately measure them
the compound
on even for ms one ms2 um level the
fragment the problem is the the
the i for identification this is so we
can generate a very good accurate
chemical formula for that compound
but
in terms of name identification often
often we give could high percentage
you know increase the more than other
high percentage rate that could be long
name and this is a bigger problem
because our biologists that we're based
on the compound name then we do pathway
analysis so this is where we will lead
the high phosphorylator for generating
the
really uh
for not a true biological hypothesis so
that's why in the past two or three
years our field of targeted metabolic
you know strong suggestions
everybody you know trying to do unpacked
metabolic ideally you created your
in-house library so that's what we did
because that's that's
so um
with that so here is what just
demonstrated another example why the
library is important the two amino acids
they've done here one is the varying
wings of a
they are structurally obviously quite
different but chemical formula the same
fragmentation wise they are very similar
sometimes often to miss a call between
of them but when you look at the
rotation time they are very different
because this is much more hydrophilic in
18 obviously
and we have also lessened in our
facility that we did you know two years
ago uh one years ago we did the four uh
uh antarctic metabolomic for gloatamine
this is the amino acid that we find
using you know i mean this is a dark
example on health it was a disease okay
so when without our own library when we
search is we find the two pickers uh one
is the one over one one is one eighty
nine five that's what are they
identification
the worst scenario is the that the
quantitation change is opposite the
second speaker is high in the healthy
that the first speaker is high in
disease so what are we going to do so
now we have a library
when we look at the library it should be
the first one is correct when the second
one we just
close out so that's that's just how
important to demonstrate the case so
otherwise you would confuse the um
uh uh on the the the pis so now we build
up almost 1200 total speculation library
and and catalog catalog because some
overlap okay so i think um
okay so so really that the way we do now
here we add another level what we call
the mess accuracy for scan under
fragment and then add the rotation time
that's really boosted our
confident identification or annotation
for for the metabolism so the benefit is
not only now using the library
we are can help you know ongoing
the the project
but more importantly we think it's a
it's a we can retrospectively research
against the older data now we can see
how much improved uh and obviously that
will also help the other targeted
analysis for meta development i'm not
going to touch here so one of the
projects that we demonstrated
here is from
you know professor lab
gregor peck that's three years ago we
did the work no library so i wish you
they really want to con you know trying
to look at that metabolism analysis for
15 different cultiva on on the april
jails and then really trying to know
what's the composition change or what
they are
in terms of polyphenol composition and
obviously the goal they're trying to do
is identify those on applications
contain the sufficient
and and journalists um endogenous
polyphenol for industrial scale then
obviously you don't need to ad for some
of the episodes for certain
um you don't add the edit that's always
the best
so greg
groper already did the analysis at the
beginning that's what the slide he
showed me so is just the two
cultivar april april side that they use
and here you can look at a lot of
difference in terms of composition the
abundancy um by the polyphenol one of
the pro and citadel obviously obviously
particularly one of the car journey the
rest is
um uh
flavonoids but
of course greg did only 10 and obviously
he tried to get him more
uh information so we did it was
three years ago that's 2018 i remember
so that's that's the triplicate 2015 and
then go to our routine way to do the
analysis and and to get the metabo uh
antagonic uh profiling
metabolites uh we did the initial search
and now we just go back to using our own
library research and then see what do we
get okay what is the difference
so here we go
um this is the 4000 feature we
identified in those samples 45 total 45
example and the june 2018 that's what
the only public database available we
identify
300 annotated 328 compound and the 49
was polyphenol compound
now just the last a few months ago the
chica did the research so we find the 4
414
and now we find a hundred or two
components and the reason why because
you can see in terms of number
you know 16
now the the total number gain is a
polyphenol and that's because our now
library including quite a bit of
flavonoids and the polyphenol component
that's another total surprise
to us okay so here i just quickly show
up with some of the compound we kind of
this is the polyphenol and you can see
it you know in the 15 episode they are
very different in terms of abundance so
you can see i just show those two
polyphenols down here first
and and then i show a couple you see oh
sorry one important things i should
yeah
so principle component analysis we can
see it you know this is the original 49
polyphenol and you can see they are
really 15 however they belong to three
group and and then now we research this
regard was slighter change but overall
um was the same and qc is a mixture
altogether you see our data analysis is
really
relatively reproducible we can't and
then greg already told me caller and the
zebra they both actually a very close
genomic background and that's what
exactly we find here as well so uh so i
want to go too quickly and then again
this is the show
um it's called the uh on gallic acid and
this was belonging to the three group
you know there's the one group we can we
can require this all three
uh cultivar uh sligo but the rest of the
same and the next one we
yeah so next one we just show you know
both the cafe acid and
another flavonoid compound those are
you know accumulated or more in the you
know those two color and the zipper
that's that's so you can actually define
the which
species or which are called evol right
contained more so um
so i to summarize what this project is
that we did was
we just want to show the
the in-house spectacular how important
the help not only ongoing project is
very important they can actually
retrospectively have the all the data we
acquired with the current
and the library will build up as long as
we're using the same condition
together to get the data so that's i
just want to
send the message out
so last
i hope last 15 minutes or 10 15 minutes
i want to show
another
new technique or technology we
implemented or developed in our facility
which is really health
and this is technology the name called
the substructure-based profiling and the
annotation workflow
for high slope identification of novel
tomato
flavonoids so now we're talking about
the flavonoids so this is a projector uh
was whether we got lucky working with
professor johnson uh and laws lab
you know um i know there's a long
thing interesting for just in jazz and
gold but they're working
on curtin
critical research
um and then we know tomato is an
excellent model for critical research
because
um they have a very good published
annotated genome sequence and the other
genomic tool available more importantly
because they have a very thick tomato
has a very thick uh remarkably thick you
know
cuticle and then this is just the
shoulder across the section of the floor
that you can see and this is obviously
critical um being stained by
by red color under so that you can
highlight the house second and then this
is the uh what we call the this is the
pikachu's just show the cuticles
it's naturally orange color because of
um contained a lot of flavor noise
particularly knowledge in chocolate okay
so so this is a project that are also
interesting the kind of critical
represent the extracellular components
for foreign noise and and
and
this is the epidemic side which we
really represent the intracell
components so how we we can find the
difference okay
so now
for the flavonoids um
you know we everybody know is a plant
the secondary metabolites right so
chemically
you know it contains 15 carbon scaling
with two
phenol ring
and connected by heterocycline in the
middle so that's called abc
and the stretch of very diversity and
the the main factor the contributors
diversity is because the glycol
conjugates
because a lot of different the sugar put
on there with a different position and
different type of sugar and the whole
different number of the sugar that's why
so so everybody knew for illinois is
very important the components to to our
health like our dietary components to
our health animals but more also more
important for everybody they have very
good biological function right so um but
for here
is the pathway forever noise since it
passed away
uh which is the
most important the enzyme done here is
called the
uh synthesis done here and we
highlighted here is red called chs okay
remember we were talking more so in
tomato the the gene the chs gene was
well catalyzed there's two of them see
you know to consistent as a gene
and the silence the both gene will
produce the purple um um
fluid instead of orange because you
completely knock out
the the orange color knowledge in
and other flavonoids so that's the
opposition
so
so justin grove this is a um working on
you know obviously this is a gene
expression this is a gene expression
interface what we call expression cuba
um with the top 10
core expression the gene
along with the important one we already
say in the ch is the first
step okay so um this is a cable really
show a 3d map a hidden map and and you
know of the gene expression across
this is a this is in one dimension
across you know different tissue from
seizures outer epidermic and then
in the different developer stage in the
second dimension
and the head part in the third dimension
is here is
really the gene included the three six
of them important related
for a person along with chsc hs2
and then
and then along with the one this is the
transpiration factor actually in
regulation all those um some of the
pathway genes
so to make a long story short those are
the ten those are the top ten that we
already find the seven of the top 10
those gene here from 35 000
was functionally related
with function related flavonoid biases
so so this is the
polynomial
um uh transcribing the data so to
complete it to transcribe the data
so what we're trying to do here
is
um we're trying to answer the
okay how many okay how many flavonoids
we can annotate identify from both the
cuticle or
epidermis cell well we later on without
and more importantly we also know what's
the distribution between critical and
the pure sample we will touch that
in terms of this project and then the
finally also very important is what's
the mechanism mechanism what particular
traffic mechanism of the forever
knowledge mechanism
um you know trafficking mechanism
between
cuticle and
epidermal cell
so um so we started with that question
when we designed the experiment
obviously so justin grover did this is
the wider type well psn but really
including both intel cell
uh on flavonoids and secreted really
integrated both and and he did using
crisp custom nine knockout the three
mutant gene and we did five lubricates
and same things for the same for using
critical and then we we normalized it by
the same weight as the weight same and
this is how we did this start from 40
samples
now
to analyze the frame noise um
there's always challenges because we
already knew that majority um forever
noise is
glycoconjugates right uh you know
majority of glycogen so there's
obviously no really standard compound
available and
because of a glycosidic it's very weak
bond in respect so in ms2 when you this
is a loading one here just just to show
example when you add sms2 you give your
two people there's no further
fragmentation therefore you cannot
really identify yes you're not sure
whether this is the forever noise or not
so that's why we need additional level
and message to the server then for the
fragment the course structure then we
know this is a definitely necessity okay
so we know uh and then again if you this
is a this is iron if you don't mess up
they just give you a lot of additional
water addition the sugar and then they
give you the cursing and you need a
message to the four because i cannot
draw but i just dropped this side and
this is the four then you know for sure
this is this is the structure how we
identify
so we take advantage of our
we we have a new we have an instrument
that this is the
um
2015 well 60 now almost 70
60 years ago we got and this is called a
tribulation instrument with a very high
accuracy allowed us to do really
well they claimed up to 10 a message to
the 10 but pragmatically maximal we
really can to do a message to the five
in terms of sensitivity we can see so we
take advantage of that allowed us to
facilitate structural error
deterioration and
identification
isomeric
so um the the component okay so here is
the way how we did it
so um
the way we did it was um what we call
the investor n basically that means that
we have to go to ms3 and mr4 okay for
identification for forever noise
if it turns out that in the example
contain the only those cross structure
and we have a database when we search we
already knew okay this is a this is
yeah this is a this isn't known
uh and entertain let's see sorry
this is drawing me crazy yeah okay
so
okay so
the previously if you already have a
database they actually directly identify
what they are but most of the case like
when you're invested two you couldn't
identify like this is a compound
and then you go to the investor to the
third okay now you find that this is a
cost stretch 317 and the 317 when you do
database say okay we find that this is
called the s heming down here and this
is clearly a flavor noise because of
that then we know okay this
641 has to be for every noise because
that's just because they contain the
cleveland or the course structure so we
are we identified that analysis by
identifying
flavonoids class first so
this is a two data analysis process i
want to quickly you know this is more
technical the first step we use in
software
the software allowed us to analyze those
it's called
msn3 data you know you have one two
three four or even five you have three
data normally you the software you
couldn't do but a mess frontier allows
you to do so then we can by doing that
search we know
okay those are the compounds contain the
core glycogen structure of foreign we
know those are
what we call flavonoids class compound
after that then we put regular like a
database search called compound discover
we we can annotate we can identify what
they are so let's see next step okay
so
now if we turn out we identify those
components in compound discover or in
mass frontier there's a way this is
called
we're doing routinely called fragmentary
search so how we know what's that we
based on mass spec fragment iron see if
they match the structure so the
measuring structures they call the fish
they just take the first word called the
fish search for ranking structure for
example this is a because remember the
flavonoid compound contains a lot of
sugar and they have
a lot a lot of eye supplies available
their mess basically exactly the same so
how you determine which one is which
okay so the way do you rely on a message
to the three or in messages to the four
you see this is the structure kinfollo
this is struggled down here the
emissions three down here support this
is the
flavor no
okay it's a kim follow forever not
because it's real high geographical over
here but this one actually is not this
one that comes out early this one
actually very wrong because there's no
hydrogen group over here so clearly
enemies to the third or ambition to the
force will
tell us which one is bad and the way we
don't need it manually we're just using
fish
fragment that match which one is best to
us
so so overall to summarize we have a
fine 562
flavonoids in in the in those samples
obviously the difference is pure and the
critical which we expect um there's
quite a difference but
regarding the transporter versus the
white tiger we we really didn't find
not much that difference
but one of those things i want to talk
about how we
identify those unknown this is a this is
what we call the putative structure of a
novel
in other words there's no public
available this is a novel component we
identified from justin's example
is you know this is a typical when we do
the database search happening this is a
substructure available in database and
once available we know okay we we find
that this is a has to be this is the
major structure down here
is from here this is substrate but now
the mass didn't match right the mass is
a lot more we have to have a 278 the
compound is here so what i did was
basically i do the
um you know 278 and based on
fragmentation i miss two ms3 i know
there's
pentose there's another pentose that
should be here
and then i come under the mass has to be
additional 146 or 367. our mass as i
said a very accurate cannot be long and
that fit is what that this is the
chromatic acid and that chromatic acid
bond here and then the mess everything
that would perfectly fit our
fragmentation and this is the one
reasonably is the most
exciting we find that well for this
project in my view is
we actually identified well
a putative amino acid conjugated another
not really much well i didn't see it
record on this one
and this is this is
we we find the three different form i i
just want to use this one as an example
it's a it's it's
it's amazing the current that we believe
is the system is form it's called design
is a bond down here
and this gives us perfectly fit for all
ms2 ms3 and ms4 in multiple form we
should uh beautifully this is this is a
one of the so so obviously this is um
uh we're going to try into what we
planned to do the nmr to validation that
is structural and then they only present
the in
in um include in in uh
epidemic say in pure example but not
absolutely not in critical at all
so so this is overall just the summary
of the connotation
um connotation is basically psm for you
can see
those are the norwegian is dominant in
psm but now legend
way way way dormant is like cursing
velocity and came from without me in the
critical which is those are yeah you
know and religion choking is a lot
strong in terms of anti-oxidation then
narration that makes sense you know in
critical they have a much stronger sims
in terms of flavonoids composition
there's much higher strong and
accuration
feature
so to summarize what we get for this
project we identified so the 562 and the
jazz well more than 300 in tomato was
new but in the total database we
searched we find the total 75 was normal
yeah we cannot hit any existing database
and we already kind of
in determined 16
putative structure
interested in for jasmine we find that
26 out of those
are much much higher the level in
cuticle
than in pure sample in other words in
extracellulars much higher than
intracellulase and all those other
compositions so so we highlighted here
the red you know means the high in the
in the pure sample and then orange was
in critical sample so so we
we kind of answered the question what
and where and now obviously the
important question is
what's the traffic mechanism and if
there is any transport allowed
you know responsible for specific
forever noise transport from epidemic
cell to to critical and this is a we
hope the data we will dig deeper and now
we can figure out what what it is um on
on this and then and as i said where
does all the process oh well
so
all right so um
and then a lot of questions you can ask
whether those those traffic mechanism
related enzyme medical uh you know
regulation or not how they produce it in
you know uh what's it called how they
they formed in uh extra um the epidermic
cell under that compound cuticle or
whether the you know um
um where how how how that function doing
what we still um need to figure out so
the last that i want to um just though
obviously not least is acknowledge those
uh the lab
we present the data in here and the more
important i want to acknowledge those
two you know any ring brain uh the new
equipment that allows us to do a lot of
work now this is the latest one or
real-time search and through hhmi and
this is our nih grant um i also want to
particularly mention frankie the bti and
tedx and hazard usda they provide as a
gift for the standard compound allowed
us to do the um the data analysis uh to
do to making the library so
um
with that i want to thank you everybody
for your attention on
you know running five minutes late
sorry um so if you have any questions
i'd like to um answer
any questions you might have thank you
dr zhang
you know use the data actually
identifies so
many actually normal compounds are genes
passage of the junction here
so if you
think seriously about your project you
should be able to just contact dr john
any questions
or any question from the audience
you should be able to see it
let's see it's here here in the chat
oh great talk uh great talk from jay
okay
so if not i have a question actually
about your first uh rtx
the rts improvement
is it because of software improvement or
just technical
improvement because it seems to me
retained spectrum strain horns right
mass mass and mass
both of them for example compare with
with
sps
the previous uh ms3 actually so it's
actually the same but the improvement is
the real time is because of software
improvement or really technically
uh mainly software this is a this is a
very good impression of professor again
technically we can we can running this
is the real-time search in object fusion
as long as they give us they give us the
software so really software can control
real-time search
there's a little bit related to the
hardware because now the new instruments
are getting fast
so in in other words you know the scan
rate everything fast like i've showed
data because the latest instrument is
going to be something around the 10 to
15 more because that's what they fast so
so the answer is yes you can use in any
instrumentation
as long as they have a data type but can
do a message to the third you can do it
like a hey once the machine also you can
do it but the problem is the company we
want to sell the latest instrument the
one letter you do
so in other words now we dedicate only
that instrument to the software only in
the latest instrument the older
instrument
we can do but that didn't bother us
because we can use another instrument
therefore small molecule for other
purpose like a waste and like
you know for foreign identification
so so that's the
that's a that's the yeah the software is
the main things that's great thank you
yeah and the other questions yes yeah
um
where you're maybe going up to ms to the
fifth or whatever how many
ms-1 peaks can you target that are
coming off at the same time
oh so so we
so so those are msn they because the
machine is very fast right a position
the way they do is this leg and well i
well i didn't show that slide but you
selected the one precursor on the major
and your flagger and this two and this
three so the way that the machine is
once if you said that emission to the
five they would do all the way to
investor five obviously the reason why i
well i just the reason why um i said ms
practically ms5 is not
i must advise the okay i messed six or
the investment 10 wouldn't work because
it's just no sensitivity because of once
you look at one level your sensitivity
dropper by almost a tenfold so that's
why okay so to answer your question ms
so they do from msn1 and ms2 ms3 and mr4
they didn't finish one first and then
select the next one as long as your
machine set up the cycle you know you
want the machine set the cycle three
seconds or four seconds so that well
usually less than three seconds because
you want to also doing quantitation at
the same time so in order to do
quantitation
you really need enough data points your
what we call the service scan in ms one
so that's why you compromise this you
might have missed something low about
the time because of doing that so the
way machine setup is
if you set a message to the end a
message three or and misses to the five
we normally said the only opportunity
message to the five so they just the
other way to finish one thing as long as
above your slasher threshold hold your
setup so they will finish this one and
then go to next go to the next did i
answer your question
yeah so it sounds like it does take
maybe a couple seconds yes and so if you
have pretty narrow peaks there maybe
five or so seconds you're somewhat
limited there in terms of maybe just
targeting one at a time yeah if well
that's that's a that's a good question
yeah if
for what you're talking about is you're
trying to target some you already knew
or you are interested right trying to
further characterize categorize for
example if i have a compound
nine i just make up 985 this is the
component of m plus h is there so i want
to
categorize if that's the case you can
just set up a target i even don't look
at the rest i just targeted that one if
you have a one what i'm talking about
today is we're trying to screen we're
trying to find anything
they are the belong the flavonoids so
we're using the msn to fish out
what they are whether it's forever noise
or not and what change
so that's more complex way we do it
i hope i answer your question yeah thank
you so i have another question regarding
that um sort of improving course
chemical library
so you should you said previously
library are essentially without any um
uh retention coins so you incorporate
your retention coins into your library
yeah but you know actually location
buying uh
depends on many factors
uh you know you already mentioned that
depends on the different conditions
because retention could be different
yeah so um
so yeah in other words if somebody has
generated data from
other machines or whatever you cannot
use your library right
yes that's that's the reason why this is
a one of the issue when i um i
i didn't mention
when you're using the library you have
to stick with the same hlc
same solvent
the condition because otherwise the
rotation time change that's right that's
the reason why
this is a tough duck this is a tough
question and then paragraph is hard is
not every level has that kind of
resource able to make in library for
themselves that's right that's the
problem so for example i just showed
here
like the the where medical school
facility director just a total machine i
just cannot do it because we they they
just so if we are medical school faculty
they are going to shipping their sample
to us so we will do here because we are
just lucky we get the some additional uh
free gift they're able to make into the
library and that's that's yeah and
that's why
you really cannot
using somebody else's library and using
for us because anything column is also
import different title column detection
time shift
so um so that's
yeah that's that's always a
very very tough one but but cornell we
are we're lucky we're trying to keep
well one thing is i want to
send the message out
is we're trying to keep building up more
and more so you know
as i said as later on
we can do the true expectative research
so even your data generated now i mean
two years from now when once we add a
more library you we can still do
research you get a benefit so
what do you generally use for internal
standards are you using like
one internal standard based on the
collapse of the compound or are you
spiking in a mixture of internal
standards um there are four you you're
talking about the untouchable
metabolomics
okay so that's that's a good question so
for regarding internal standard okay so
this is the that's the also field i'm
talking a few other consensus so this is
the way how fields are doing
for antarctic
metabolomical
the
we we're using two different types what
we call standard also
quality control
one type of standard like you said that
we normally using um i think seven right
more than seven it is just different
type of stand however that standard only
using the for our for four hour called
qa quality assurance
and
just to make sure our system
every you know you maybe every every
bench we started running we make sure
our machine everything is okay
so the really using the the the what we
call qc quality control to answer your
question
is we're going to use in the
the mixture of each of the sample as
as the quality it was called qc sample
and there's a two way one way it's
called a global qc that's if you have a
40 sample like adjacent here that's what
we did if you have a 40 sample we make
it all for the equally together that's
called global qc the second qc is called
global accuracy global casey is we have
integral over 95 example we make it
together called global qc for global
global altogether qc we're normally
using for normalization
of the quantitation profiling so what
that means
uh this is this is the the reason why we
need quality
we need a qc sample we're actually
running every five example we're running
qc
the sample and then we're using qc order
on the intensity to normalize the
software allowed us normalized back and
the reason why you know right the
machine when you're running day one on
the first example versus the day three
the last example the machine response
effect the awesome everything is going
to drop and the curve is like this
is a starter drop and then if you don't
normalize
you you you introduce artificial right
the quantitation change is another kind
obviously we're using random running
that we've really heard your statistic
but after the normalize then everything
is bring back and then i want to add one
more why we need a group accuracy
because the global accuracy we're using
identification or annotation because
this global versus other group white
type reversal mutant could be compound
very different so we're using both
separated the identification rate that
would be a lot of high so that's what we
do
so this is that's good and
again we we're always using the standard
compound as a qa quality assurance
you know in our system is fine and the
qc really using the normalize make sure
the data is going to be bring back to
the everybody is you know basically the
same level so that's what we use you're
just normalizing
that's right
yeah that's right that's that's the
question and then again qa sample is
only for check
yeah thank you for the question thank
you so much
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu